[Music]
you know one of the things that is
definitely on my bucket list and i hope
to do one day
but that kind of made me scared too
because of the story is to do
a safari trip oh
do you want to experience i want to
experience what it's like to see
wild animals and
[Music]
yeah yeah i want to see what like the
lion king in real life
okay you want to see rafiki
pull a bear cub i mean a lion cub hold
it up
she's gonna be disappointed yeah damn it
have you seen there's that like that
house
uh uh in africa where it's like the
giraffes are there and the drafts are
like all up in the windows and you're
eating breakfast they peek their heads
through and [ __ ]
wait i saw i thought they they did that
at animal kingdom
yeah in disneyland i mean disney world
all right wherever it was man it's right
in our backyards i've seen something
i do do that i'm down for that though i
saw ostrich go into a car to eat a snack
and a baby grab
its necklace and not in here what is
that real yeah for real
[ __ ] all right well i have a story that
takes place in tanzania tanzania
tanzania tanzania
thank you tasmania or tanzania yeah
cause i was thinking tanzanite or
tennessee
or that right oh it could be texas
tasmania
tanzania thank you okay okay so tanzania
yes that one
tallahassee it takes place there and so
there was this
couple who are currently 64 years old
and 63 years old
so it's patrick and bridget or bridget
bridget
and so they are friends or the project
get that right
while they were on this trip one of the
nights in a different camp because they
had been camping already in this one
camp and then they moved over to this
other camp
i get scared of camp in africa so at
that second camp
when they were sleeping they got woken
up because a lion
was inside of their tent oh [ __ ] oh my
[ __ ] that's the worst thing you can
imagine didn't use a zipper stupid asses
[Laughter]
lift well they said that they thought
they were safe being in that mesh
net as well because like probably
mosquitoes or whatever you gotta zip
all that [ __ ] there's snakes there's
[ __ ]
cockroaches the size of the fists they
got all kinds of animals in africa yeah
what are they doing they're in there
eating turkey legs looking at the stars
i know
well they were sleeping well maybe the
lion wanted to cuddle
yeah mine's like y'all up what are you
guys doing we are from you wake
what do you do at that point just hold
your breath like what would you do
i would hold my breath and just don't
move then try to hold but hopefully they
go away
or if i wake up and he's um next to me
i guess he wants to be little spoon so
i'm putting my arm over
that's pretty good yeah so they woke up
and this lion was sniffing brigitte
and oh he wasn't cuddling oh boy he was
like
like sniffing her she was like recycling
blue i don't have any but that's here
and then he attacked patrick
oh he mauled him while he was sleepy
i don't know exactly the timeline of
things she didn't woke up the point is
they were asleep they got woken up by
this lion he got mauled to the point
where
the lion took a chunk out of his arm out
oh
[ __ ] he punched him in his [ __ ] nose
that's right
i'm sure they tried it all should have
stared at the line and established
dominance yeah
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] are you doing hipster i
don't know i'm imagining they're
hipsters with a
very nice pinch before 63 year old
hipsters could be hipster at 16.
oh 60s they probably got that old
bicycle with the big wheel and the
little wheel [ __ ]
and a top hat yeah this is brigitte and
patrick
they should have just fed him the
baguettes they had i know
so this happened back in 2015 when this
attack happened
it looked like he got one pant on like
it's not there's no leg it's just one
because of the shadow it looks like one
bag
i could see them on a penny far thing
that's the one bicycle with the
big that's what it's called the penny
farther farthing
penny farthing how do you know this [ __ ]
i did a show called diamond yacht club
look at his thank you
these are my roots buddy it's my history
man that's like using abacus
ah same [ __ ] or rickshaw yeah there we
go
all right so patrick he has undergone 10
surgeries to reconstruct his left arm
poor dude and he's expected to
undergo more he got rearranged that bad
yeah
but also what the [ __ ] you in the jungle
in africa but then the wife was like
right why did was i not tasty or what
probably the lion sniffed her was like i
know
that he tried to protect the wife was
like like one of those like get the [ __ ]
away from my wife and then he ended up
taking
let's say yes okay because that's kind
of tight what if the wife was awake
because she was like don't make any
noise then he goes
i believe that one more that's the one i
believe
the most but yeah
okay so now at this point the reason why
we're talking about the story is because
they are now suing the travel agency
responsible for organizing this trip or
like the company which is a british
company
and they're saying that they had failed
to
to protect them they've yeah they failed
to put uh
to keep the lions out of the campground
yeah and they're saying like they could
have been surveillance like there could
have been way more things they could
have done to prevent this attack so tell
people there's lions you should zip up
your tent
or you should feed the lions outside the
encampment so they're not hungry coming
in yeah where's your exotica when you
need them man come on man
so oh so it's like a designated area of
camping at this
situation i'm assuming yeah i'm assuming
that they
because they organize these trips and
they're supposed to be like the best
like african safari trip organizers or
whatever
well they got really close to the lions
alliance
maybe that was the whole thing it's like
you'll be inches away from the lines and
they're like really
unforgettable yeah and unforgettable
he's like hey we gave you the experience
you wanted
super vr you wanted the authentic
african experience you got it
well they didn't want this experience so
i'm going to show you guys photos
of patrick's oh that's going to make the
comedy go away i do
he's alive though right i do want to see
yeah okay okay okay then it's still fine
surgeries i do want to see it though
poor dude
it is blurred out why still because
that's how they gave it to us i don't
know that they provided the media
outlets with
oh um but even blurred out i'm still
like
so ready what you know it's like i'm
watching japanese porn
where is that what is that i see a
nipple oh so that's his forearm his arm
he's going like this right
oh that's his elbow this whole thing is
taken out right it's all triceps
oh that's really bad these whole triceps
that's a big dude man
god i can't throw a ball anymore i know
that's true
thank god it was a left one though right
oh you can see the bite mark it's just
even if it's bloody yeah you can see the
shape of it
dude it's that big that's insane
that's a big mouth man
that's how civilized we are is we're
like dang that's his arm that's his ball
throwing arm
yeah it's a left arm it's not a spear
arm yeah yeah
no none of that it's a baseball he can't
hunt anymore we're like no no he can't
he can't throw a tennis ball
anymore he can't play drive a tesla with
that arm like that
he'll never be able to throw a paper
airplane again that's insane
oh it's poor man i mean wouldn't that be
that or
go ahead wouldn't that be the first
thing you ask when you go to an african
campsite like are there any
lions here right and they're like don't
worry about you stupid tourists it's
like okay thanks thing it's gotta be on
the release form though i know cause
like even here when i go to campgrounds
i'm thinking about bears
right or oh yeah mountain lions or
whatever because it's
it's not like people don't be so scared
idiot it's like no but they but they're
here though yeah right or like if you're
swimming in
hawaii there are sharks right like
they'll have signs that's like they
spotted the [ __ ] tiger shark get out
of the [ __ ] water
but that's like saying eh that's nature
i'm gonna swim
yeah you know just not even taking into
account the risks
but i guess for them they were just like
well we paid all this money because it's
a luxury
kind of trip you know this money like
why
why can't you keep us safe like what the
[ __ ] it's like bare minimum you could
have done
for them and so they're saying that as
like since
then they have been struggling with
mental health problems
oh no they're suffering from depression
and ptsd
and they think the lion's gonna show up
everywhere now i [ __ ] wake up in my
king-sized bed like there's a line in my
room yeah it's traumatic
dude that happened to me when i watched
jaws as a kid and i'm i'm not even
kidding when you go swimming you just
think there could be a shark somewhere
oh yeah the opening scene of jaws where
the girl's like
never seen jaws but growing up because
of pop culture references and stuff i
had always been afraid of
like when i was little of a shark being
in the pool right exactly
in the pool that's what i'm talking
about same [ __ ]
yeah it just doesn't make sense it's
because you know that there's some kind
of connection where they get the water
from somewhere so you're worried that a
shark got in there somehow
yeah you're thinking about it you're
like nine you're like in a bathtub with
a rubber ducky like
man you know until this day like just
yesterday i had this thought crossed my
mind
where i i opened up the toilet and i'm
like there could be a snake there you
never know but i'm like
this is the second floor
not in mexico anymore tiff i know
but i couldn't help but still have that
thought crossed my mind where i'm like
you never know what could crawl out of
the [ __ ] toilet in australia when
they're hungry they're like oh there
could be a snake in the toilet
and they're like okay we have to go to
mcdonald's
i've heard a [ __ ] like even in
florida like gators in the toilet or
something like that
there's gators on the freeway yeah
they're just [ __ ] walking around and
[ __ ] everywhere all over the place yep
yeah they're like pigeons that have
teeth true
they can't fly yep if i got bit by a
lion though i'd be just super grateful
i'm even alive true oh yeah that's like
you know those shark bites when people
are like surfing or whatever
you see half of their boards gone yeah
yeah they survive it or they have like a
big
bite mark on their chest or whatever i'm
like damn
dude and they go back into the water
people are
pretty brave you know just for what i
would have to do
to get redemption is i would have to go
out and
fish a shark and kill one oh really
i would have to get revenge yeah because
their energy
has to be soaked up in my body yeah so
then the shark can smell that i'm a
shark hunter
and then they won't try to bite me
anymore because they'll be like oh this
guy eats sharks
let's get the [ __ ] out of here so what
should patrick and um
they should go eat a lion yeah they
should go get one
and then eat a lion and then fart lion
like what do you call it like like like
digestions
yeah right and then the other lions go
don't [ __ ] with patrick
or just take a big lion [ __ ] in the
middle of the campground
these guys eat lions yeah so next time
on the line she lands me like oh man
this lady eats lady's lion she got lion
breath yeah
lying [ __ ] it's not good because i heard
that if you eat dog and you go home
your dog will look at you and be like
bro
i'm disappointed come on man yeah
what about those people that have pigs
as pets do you think they still eat
pork probably because people are trash
that's true yeah they just think they're
really cute yeah
i would be one of those people i could
see myself eating bacon and have a baby
pixie
i could see you feeding some to the pig
no no no no
pigs are [ __ ] cute though not right i
know and they're so cute they're really
cute
even when i went to like a [ __ ] uh a
frog leg festival right they had
a whole festival yeah in florida when we
were shooting send food there's a frog's
legs festival
and um and they had a little thing where
you could like you know pick up frogs
and [ __ ] and i was like i was like
that's weird
okay i can't do this anymore this is
making it too real i don't like this
it's weird when it's
like the food is being cooked and then
you're playing with it yeah
yeah i had a pet frog as a kid i don't
think i could eat frog what about fish
the frog legs are pretty good what about
it well like you know like like you know
like chinese restaurants or whatever you
sometimes
they'll actually fish it out for you or
like lobster at their fancy river oh
yeah
that one yeah and in that moment you
kind of have a bit of a connection with
it don't you and then you end up not
like i eat that one
[ __ ] let's do it i can't do it i
try to name it first
i try to figure out the price yeah i
know it's too big and this is affordable
we'll call him sad we'll call him saturn
or yummy and delicious
[Music]
do